The answers are, for the first one, the dates are the same. We said that was
okay. The requirement is that the second date cannot be before the first date.
It's fine if they're the same. And then the answer should be 0, there are no
dates, between those two. The second one, the second input is one day after the
first input, so the output should be 1. For the third one, the second date is
before the first date. The way we specify the problem. That's an invalid input.
That means the output is undefined. And, our procedure could actually be
correct, no matter what it does for this input. It'd be more useful if it gives
a clear error message or maybe even more useful if it gives negative 1. But the
way we specify the problem, we don't have to worry about what the output is
there, because we're saying that these inputs are invalid. For the fourth one,
the dates are a year apart, June 29 in 2013 is one year after June 29 in 2012.
And so, there are 365 days in a non-leap year. And it's non-leap year because
the February that's included is the February in 2013. For the final one, we're
going from June 29, 2012 to June 31st, 2013. If you know your calendar well, you
know there's actually no June 31st. The way we specified the problem, we said
that both input dates have to be valid dates in the Gregorian calendar. That
means that the output here is undefined. We'd like to get some kind of error
output, but there's no requirement for our procedure.